نبدا اذا بالازمه بالحرب على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلن حاكم مقاطعه كورس كروسيه المحليه
المحاديه لاوكرانيا رومان ستار روموفيت عن
استهدافي مسيرات الاوكرانيه لمطار مدينه
كورس في ساعه مبكره من صباح اليوم وقال
المسؤول الروسي ان النيران اشتعلت في خزان
وقود جراء الهجوم دون وقوع خسائر بشريه
يذكر ان مطار كورسك متوقف عن استقبال
الرحلات المدنيه منذ بدء العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا
لهجوم الاوكراني على مطرين عسكريين في
وسطه وجنوب بلاد باستخدامه
صوفيات الصلاه
عسكريين خلال الهجوم في المقابل نقلت
صحيفه نيويورك تايم
اوكرانيا لان كيف استهدفت بطائرات مسيره
قاعدتين عسكريتين على بعد مئات الاميال
داخل روسيا وقالت الصحيفه ان طائرات
المسيره انطلقت من داخل اوكرانيا فدمرت
طائرتين على الاقل في احدى القاعدتين
الروتين والحقه اضرارا بعده طائرات اخرى
هذا وقالت السلطات في زبوجيا وهي سلطات
المواليه لروسيا الى قصف اوكرانيا سادف
صباح اليوم المنطقه الصناعيه تابعه لمحطه
بروسيا للطاقه النوويه
والخسائر في الوقت الراهن وفي جورج
اكد السلطات المحليه تعرض احد مصانع
الكيماويات لقذف مدفعيا الاوكراني دون
تسجيل اصابه
تنضموا الينا من دولاس مراسله الجزيره
سلام خضرا ومن زبرجيا مراسل الجزيره تامر
الصمادي نبدا معكي سلام خبر يعني واضح انا
ساعات الاخيره شهد التطورات عديده تفضلي
عبد الصمد خاصه هنا في دنياك سواء المدينه
او المقاطعه من الواضح ان القتال ربما
الاقصى
تدور يدور روحاه في المناطق
في مناطق التماس بين الجيشين الروسي
والاوكراني نبدا من هنا من دنياتك المدينه
كانت يوم امس تحت قصف صاروخيا مكثف من
المواقع الاكرانيه
واعيد الظهر يوم امس صدنا همم طلعات جويه
متكرره سواء لسلاح الجو الروسي وحتى
للطائرات المروحيه وزاره الدفاع تقول انها
تستهدف في الطلعات الجويه مواقع اوكرانيه
متقدمه سواء هنا في دنياك او عند محاور
اخرى في لوغانسك تحديدا اليوم لفتت
مسالتين اساسيتين الاولى هنا قرب دانيات
همم في منطقه جرلفقه تعرض احد مصانع
الكيماويات لقذف اوكراني قالت انه لم يؤدي
الى وقوع ضحايا ولكن الاضرار كبيره في هذا
المصنع من دون ان تعطي مزيدا من التفاصيل
اما في منطقه زابروجيا فالسلطات الموليه
لروسيا هناك تحدثت عن ان الطائرات او عن
ان قصف اوكرانيا استهدف منشات صناعيه
تابعه لمحطه ذا بروسيا لتوليد الطاقه
النوويه نشير في هذا الايطار انه الاسبوع
الماضي شركه
تحذيرا قالت ان تكرار القصف الاوكراني
باتجاه المحطه الذريه قد يرفع من خطر وقوع
حادث النووي وصفاته بالخطير وقالت شركه
انذاك ان استمرار القصف من الجانب
الاوكراني يحول المنطقه وايضا دول محيط
اوكرانيا وروسيا الى
رهائن بحسب ما قالته ان ذاك الشركه
المشاغله حاليا في محطه النوويه
سلام خضر ماضي ايضا ساعات الماضيه كانت
حافله بالقصف والاستهدافات في مناطق عده
ماذا لديك
نعم بالفعل سلمان تطورات في عموم المناطق
الجنوبيه والشرقيه وفقا لهيئه الاركان
الاوكرانيه وقياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه هنا تحديدا في زبروج طيله
الليله الماضيه وفجر هذا اليوم وصباح هذا
اليوم ونحن نستمع الى القصف الذي لا يهدا
تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه بان القوات
الروسيه تواصل قصفها لزبروجا والقصف
والقصف المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه تحديدا بالمدفعيه يجري على تخوم
المدينه من خلف تلك الغابه والغابه التي
تليها ويفصل بينهما نهر الدنبر الاصوات لا
تهدا لا تنقطع تتحدث القوات الاوكرانيه عن
قصف متبادل بالمدفعيه تحديدا وتقول بانها
تكثف من قصفها ل- اا ريف زباروجيا الجنوبي
تحديدا مدينه ميليتوبيل التي تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت الروسيه عفوا كانت
هنالك تصريحات مهمه خلال الساعات الماضيه
لمستشارين في الرئاسه همم
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه قالوا بان القوات
الاوكرانيه تكثف بالفعل من قصفها
لميليتوبل لانها تريد ان تقطع خطوط
الامداد كما قالت عن القوات الروسيه
المتواجده في المحطه محطه الطاقه النوويه
في الانقدار والاضافه الى المتواجدين في
محيطها وتقول ايضا بان هنالك في محيط
المحطه قتال دائر على اكثر من محور على
اكثر من جبهه والحديث ايضا من قبل القوات
الاوكرانيه عن قصف روسي تتعرض له العديد
من القرى والبلدات المحيطه والمجاوره
للمحطه النوويه ونحن حاولنا مرارا الخروج
بث مباشر من محيط المحطه لكن هنالك رفض
وتشدد من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه في هذا
السياق التطورات ايضا في خير سون هنالك
مواجهات مستعره تقول السلطات الاوكرانيه
بان القوات الروسيه المتواجده على الضفه
الاخرى من نهر دنيبر قصفت خلال الساعات
الماضيه اكثر من 20 بلده وقريه تقع على
خطا التماس وفي المقابل تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه بان قصف متبادلا يجري على ضفتي
النهر ايضا بالمدفعيه التطورات ايضا في
ميكولاي في اوديسا القصف الذي تعرضت له
ميكولايب وادسه الليله الماضيه من بحر
قزوين من البحر الاسود يعني اوقف خدمه
الماء والكهرباء بالكامل عن المدينه
السلطات هناك تقول بانها تعمل على اعاده
الماء والكهرباء بشكل تدريجي ايضا
التطورات في منطقه همم نيكوبيل القريبه
ايضا من المحطه النوويه محطه الطاقه
النوويه في الزباروجا والتي تقع ضمن حدود
مقاطعه وسط جنوبيه البلاد هذه المنطقه
التي افرغت بشكل كبير من السكان وهنالك
بني تحتيه فيها للقوات الاوكرانيه تحديدا
وتواجد وتمركز لا الق اسال الاوكرانيه
تتعرض لقصف مستمر ومتواصل خلال الساعات
الماضيه وفقا للروايه الاوكرانيه الحديث
عن اكثر من 80 قذيفه مدفعيه سقطت على
المنطقه خلال الساعات الماضيه التطورات
ايضا في خارقيف شرق البلاد خلال الساعات
الاخيره ايضا بث الجيش الاوكراني لقطات
لحطام ما قال انها طائره مقاتله روسيه واا
بقايا عتاد قائد الطائره وقال بانه قضى في
هذا في هذه الحادثه التي اسقطت فيها
القوات الاوكرانيه هذه الطائره والحديث
ايضا عن قصف مدفعي تتعرض له العديد من
مناطق خارقين في هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
والحديث ايضا عن قصف متتالي المدفعيه ل-
اكثر من 17 منطقه في الدنيا تسيطر عليها
القوات الاوكرانيه ونهايه كما تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه محاوله محاولات عديده
لصد هجوم باتجاه باخم جديده شرقي البلاد
نعم شكرا لك مراسلنا تامر الصمادي من
زبروشه